et elle a recommencé à chanter et à
manger
pourtant thérèse-marie no 85 ans
atteinte de lakovic 19 avait été déclaré
en fin de vie si seulement pour cette
raison que son fils projets dans avait
été autorisée à lui rendre visite
c'est ce qu'on appelle un motif
humanitaire c'était fini fallait que je
la vois dans les prochains heures avant
qu'elle devienne trop comateuse real
mignon a retrouvé sa mère déboussolé
déshydraté effrayés par les visages
qu'il ne reconnaissait plus derrière
l'équipement de protection au fur et à
mesure que j étais [ __ ] n y sas à
laquelle mais beaucoup avant d'essayer
de la femme âgée plus malfaisant écouter
des chansons
ces petits gestes par petits gestes
elle a commencé a défié les probabilités
pour moi c'était c'était les sports qui
revenait capuche travail et elle va
mieux
indéniablement la présence quotidienne
de son fils y est pour beaucoup
effectivement la six nations qui lui ont
donné peu il aulas le fait que le tout
se soit renversé
ce ne serait pas le seul petit miracle
pour sept médecins plusieurs décès en ch
et celle des pourraient être évités si
les aidants naturels été autorisé à voir
leurs proches
québec l'interdît toujours dans les
résidences où il y à une éclosion
j'ai pas assez de des doigts de tout les
gens j'ai rencontré leur qui était en
détresse au logis qui nous disait pu
vouloir les soeurs barroso ont tout fait
pour pouvoir entrer dans la résidence de
leur mère et s'occuper d'elle ils n'ont
pas réussi
je sais pas s'ils ont pu la sauver mais
on aurait pressenti ce qu'on ressent
présentement
aujourd'hui la culpabilité la ronge les
questions se bousculent
j'ai des doutes à savoir si maman est
décédée
cordier parce qu'elle était déshydratée
parce qu'elle n'avait pas bu ni mangé
depuis cinq jours c'est d'ailleurs la
grande crainte de monsieur mignot
maintenant que sa mère n'est plus
considéré en fin de vie il ne peut plus
lui rendre visite pour l'aider à se
nourrir
j'ai plus confiance que les décisions
sont prises pour sauver une vie à la
fois sa mère va mieux mais sans lui à
son chevet pour combien de temps
issigeac audry charbonneau radio canada
mon frère